you ever get nervous you're gonna get a
script and it's like brands going down
it's the first thing everyone ever gets
good day to my dad I went in with a dope
fight oh my god
it's terrifying they were and David and
Ann don't tell us anything so we're
constantly asking the makers at us is it
me this year like am I gonna die no it's
like you know what it could be so it's
like it's really terrifying when you get
the scripts - it's probably the most
tense few hours of my life really those
scripts and buy me out I think people
would be lying if they said they read
the scripts from front to back and then
when they come across themselves they're
reading I I think you look for yourself
first it's only natural you immediately
just flip to Davos and see if he makes
it out no no these scripts are too good
yeah I read them line by Lion because
you have to remember when you guys see
the show and you have those oMFG moments
when I'm read the scripts so that's
that's where and then when I see them I
see how beautifully the shot they have
beautifully directed them go Runnings
music and I see the whole tapestry of it
but when I'm reading I lock myself away
and a large pot of coffee and a nice
cake yeah put a candle
I mean hang it from the ceiling in my
tent if it happens it happens I'm not
gonna moan about it it's been a great
job and I've loved it so how would you
want to go um preferably about the age
of 90 in my sleep but I can't see us
eating that many series when you read
the script of Ramsay's death we what did
you think other than what actually I
read it and was like Jon Snow beating
him up but I thought that can't be the
way he goes rubbish and then when I
carried on reading thankfully there was
that scene and if they was so so right
that Sansa today and we're so justified
and ironic and and right and it's good
for the whole show I think to move the
story on get rid of him and then
mmm-hmm starts have got Winterfell again
and yeah okay I would say the most
satisfying death no offense
he deserved it didn't you really I kept
still kept talking about banging on
about those dogs and then the shot with
a sausage is like forever ingrained into
my brain yeah that's a lot of sausage is
that how many can't remember was too
many I didn't eat lunch put a lot